as far as supervillains go Thanos is
well not very bright see what you will
about doc ock syndrome or Lex Luthor
at least they put considerable
scientific thought behind their evil
plans nanowires feet directly into my
cerebellum meanwhile check out Santos's
master plan the entire time on earth
finals he only ever had one goal to
bring balance to the universe by wiping
out half of all life yeah this scheme to
conserve resources vile imitating half
of all life makes no sense in fact it
wouldn't save the planet it would doom
it
[Music]
let's start with his decision to wipe
out half of humanity now at first you
can see his reasoning after all there
are seven point seven billion humans on
the planet today
that's nearly 7 percent of all the
people who have ever lived in the
history of our species which makes for a
pretty crowded planet so if half of us
suddenly vanished
wouldn't that be a worthy sacrifice no
ethics aside we'd still be left with
almost 3.9 billion people about the same
world population in 1972 so if history
repeats itself it would buy us less than
50 years before we reached current
levels again and the same is true for
many animal species like deer whose
healthy populations would help them
rebound quickly but unfortunately the
same can't be said for endangered
species who have the opposite problem
take the critically endangered Sumatran
tiger
for example experts estimate there are
fewer than 400 left on the planet if
half disappeared there wouldn't be
enough to sustain the population and
they would likely go extinct and
endangered sharks hawks and leopards
would probably meet the same fate and
that's where fan OSes plan to save the
world really falls apart once a top
predator disappears they can take the
rest of your ecosystem down with them
take gray wolves for example the US
government eradicated them from
Yellowstone in the 20th century with a
wolves gone the elk population exploded
and devoured the local vegetation which
disrupted the population of beavers
birds and other species that relied on
those plants to survive and it gets even
worse once you consider that half of
every plant species on earth is gone too
because just like with animals there are
thousands of endangered plant species
many of which are too vulnerable to
survive Fano says plot
and if plant species die out the rest of
their food chain would starve
of course many plant populations aren't
endangered but even that won't save them
all in the long run you see scientists
estimate that 90% of all flowering
plants depend on animals to reproduce
but thanos wiped out half of all bees
fruit bats and every other pollinator on
the planet many of which are already in
trouble
for example 50% of bee species in the
Midwest have vanished in the past
century and the lesser long-nosed bat a
key pollinator in the Sonoran Desert is
also disappearing so they would probably
die off completely and if enough
pollinators go poof we're looking at a
possible total ecological collapse
so while thanasis plan wouldn't directly
devastate thriving species the chain
reaction that could come from
eliminating endangered species could
really mess things up for everyone else
left alive resurrections
nice going Thanos to be fair the planet
has experienced mass extinctions before
and life recovered for example an
asteroid strike 66 million years ago
wiped out 75 percent of all species on
earth and with the dinosaurs out of the
way our mammalian ancestors flourished
but even so experts estimate it takes
around 20 million to 30 million years to
recover from a mass extinction
so unless waiting around for millennia
was all part of the plan the mad Titan
messed up big time
[Music]
you